This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. The line to enter Barcelona's most famous cathedral often stretches around the block. L'Azagrata Familia, designed by Antony Gaudi, draws so many people to see it that the neighborhood is congested with tour buses and taxis and scooters. in scooters. Some three million people went inside the church in 2016, and another seven million came just to stare at the outside of this strange behemoth structure. If you travel around Spain, you'll see a lot of old Gothic churches. Producer Katie Mingle was in Spain earlier this year.
这里是 99% 隐形。我是罗曼·马尔斯。进入巴塞罗那最著名的教堂的队伍经常排得转过一个街区。由安东尼·高迪设计的圣家族大教堂吸引了如此多的人来参观，以至于附近的街区挤满了旅游大巴、出租车和踏板车。踏板车。2016年，大约有300万人进入教堂内部，另有700万人专门来看这个奇怪的庞然大物的外观。如果你在西班牙各地旅行，你会看到许多古老的哥特式教堂。制作人凯蒂·明格尔今年早些时候去了西班牙。
But this one is different. First, it doesn't look like a Gothic cathedral. It looks like it was built out of bones or sand or like it just twirled out of the sea, like a fractal. It looks organic somehow. But there's another thing that sets it apart from your average old Gothic cathedral. It isn't actually old. Gaudi wasn't able to build very much of it before he died in 1926. Most of the church has been built in the last 40 years, and it still isn't finished.
但这座教堂与众不同。首先，它看起来不像哥特式教堂。它看起来像是用骨头或沙子建造的，或者就像是从海里旋转出来的，就像分形一样。它看起来不知为何很有有机感。但还有另一件事使它区别于普通的老式哥特式教堂。它其实并不古老。高迪在1926年去世前没能建造多少。这座教堂的大部分都是在过去40年里建造的，而且至今尚未完工。
Which means that architects have had to figure out and still are figuring out how Gaudi wanted the church to be built? We are all together in a room, a special room. The most important part of the building we are building. That's Hironimo Bouchario, one of the current architects of the building. And he says the clues to understanding how to move forward on the construction of La Sacrata Familia are kept in the room we're standing in right now in the basement of the church.
这意味着建筑师们不得不弄清楚，并且现在仍在弄清楚高迪希望这座教堂如何建造？我们都在一个房间里，一个特殊的房间。我们正在建造的建筑中最重要的一部分。那是希罗尼莫·布查里奥，该建筑现任建筑师之一。他说，理解如何继续推进圣家族大教堂建设的线索，就保存在我们现在所在的这个教堂地下室的房间里。
So since this is radio, can you describe what's in this room? Ah, okay. How do you call these? Shelfs. There are a lot of shelves with fragments, little pieces of plaster, beak, small. Before he died, Galdie left elaborate plaster models, detailing his plans for finishing the church. But about 80 years ago, they were all basically destroyed.
既然这是广播节目，你能描述一下这个房间里有什么吗？啊，好吧。这些叫什么？架子。有很多架子，上面摆着碎片、小块的石膏、喙，很小的。在高迪去世之前，他留下了精心制作的石膏模型，详细说明了他完成教堂的计划。但大约80年前，它们基本上都被毁坏了。
Now they're in pieces. It doesn't look like just from this and those little pieces that that would be enough to like figure out the whole thing. Yeah, I understand that it's difficult to know what we have to do if the main architect is not here. Oh, he's not with us. What we try to do is to understand how he thought,
现在它们都碎成了碎片。仅凭这个和那些小碎片，看起来似乎还不足以弄清楚整件事。是的，我理解，如果主建筑师不在，很难知道我们该做什么。哦，他不在我们身边。我们试图做的是去理解他是如何思考的，
and it's not easy. I know. It definitely hasn't been easy for the new architects to recreate and understand the vision of Antony Gaudi, and there are people who think they shouldn't even have tried, that the building should have stopped after Gaudi's death. But it didn't. The building is currently the longest running construction project in the world, and the architects are still trying to understand the mind of Gaudi.
这并不容易。我知道。对于新建筑师来说，要重现和理解安东尼·高迪的愿景绝对不容易，有些人认为他们甚至不该尝试，这座建筑本该在高迪去世后就停止建造。但事实并非如此。该建筑目前是世界上历时最长的建设工程，建筑师们仍在努力理解高迪的想法。
Antony Gaudi grew up in a little town called Reus, which, like Barcelona, was part of a region of Spain called Catalonia. And although he's become one of Spain's most famous architects, Gaudi would never have identified as Spanish. He was Catalonian, through and through. Catalonia has been in the news recently because of its movement for independence from Spain. But in many ways, this movement isn't new. Catalonians have struggled against the rule of the Spanish for centuries. Catalonia has a separate language, Catalan. It has always felt very separate.
安东尼·高迪在一个叫做雷乌斯的小镇长大，和巴塞罗那一样，雷乌斯也是西班牙加泰罗尼亚地区的一部分。尽管他已经成为西班牙最著名的建筑师之一，但高迪从未认为自己是西班牙人。他彻头彻尾是个加泰罗尼亚人。加泰罗尼亚最近因为其脱离西班牙独立的运动而成为新闻焦点。但在许多方面，这场运动并不新鲜。几个世纪以来，加泰罗尼亚人一直在为对抗西班牙的统治而斗争。加泰罗尼亚有自己的语言，加泰罗尼亚语。它一直让人感觉非常独立。
That's Geis van Hensbergen. My name is Geisan Hensbergen, I'm the biographer of Antony Gaudi. Van Hensbergen says that as a child growing up in Catalonia, Gaudi spent a lot of time outside and was completely enthralled with the natural world around him. What he would later call the Great Book of Nature. A lot of kids are curious about nature, but for Antony Gaudi it was different. It became a total obsession. He seemed to absorb essential lessons from the patterns and shapes he saw in nature. Just looking at the way the insects were walking and flowers grew, the way that a tree grows and where it throws out branches. A dried out snake skeleton, a honeycomb,
那是盖斯·范·亨斯贝尔根。我叫盖斯·范·亨斯贝尔根，我是安东尼·高迪的传记作家。范·亨斯贝尔根说，作为在加泰罗尼亚长大的孩子，高迪花了很多时间在户外，完全被他周围的自然世界迷住了。他后来称之为“大自然这部伟大的书”。很多孩子对自然充满好奇，但对安东尼·高迪来说却不同。这成了一种彻底的痴迷。他似乎从在自然界中看到的图案和形状中汲取了基本的教训。只要看看昆虫行走的方式和花的生长方式，树木生长的方式以及它长出树枝的地方。干枯的蛇骨架、蜂窝，
these were nature's perfect constructions. And for Gaudi, a deeply religious Catholic, God was the master architect of these flawless, organic structures. Eventually Gaudi left his small town in the countryside and moved to Barcelona for university and then architecture school. When he graduated in 1878, the director of the school said, we are here today either in the presence of a genius or a madman. Gaudi began his career at a difficult moment in Barcelona. The industrial revolution had brought thousands of workers from the countryside into the city for factory jobs. They were toiling in terrible conditions, packed into filthy
这些都是大自然完美的构造。对于一个虔诚的天主教徒高迪来说，上帝是这些完美、有机结构的大师级建筑师。最终，高迪离开了乡村的小镇，搬到巴塞罗那上大学，然后进入建筑学校。当他在1878年毕业时，学校的校长说，我们今天来到这里，要么是面对一个天才，要么是一个疯子。高迪在巴塞罗那一个困难的时期开始了职业生涯。工业革命将成千上万的乡村工人带到城市做工厂工作。他们在可怕的条件下辛勤劳作，挤在肮脏的
tenements, drinking dirty water. Diseases like yellow fever and cholera were rampant. In the midst of all of this suffering, a bookseller named Josep Bocabella began selling a fundamentalist newspaper. The kind that reminded everyone that their misery was punishment for their sins. Surprisingly, at court on. Pretty soon, Bokabea was making quite a lot of money from his Catholic guilt-themed newspaper.
廉租公寓里，喝着脏水。黄热病和霍乱等疾病猖獗。在所有这些苦难之中，一个名叫何塞·博卡贝拉的书商开始出售一份原教旨主义报纸。那种提醒每个人他们的痛苦是对他们罪孽惩罚的报纸。出人意料的是，在法庭上。很快，博卡贝拉靠他的天主教负罪感主题报纸赚了不少钱。
Which he's squirreled away, kept apparently under, hidden under the tiles of his bookshop. With the piles of money he was accumulating, Bokabea decided to build a church. One meant to inspire the common folk to lead a religious life. The church would be dedicated to Mary, Joseph, and Jesus, the sacred family, Lusagrada Familia. The first architect that Bokovea hired quit after a year, and he went looking for a new one.
他把钱藏了起来，显然藏在书店的瓷砖下面。用积攒如山的金钱，博卡贝拉决定建造一座教堂。一座旨在激励普通民众过宗教生活的教堂。这座教堂将献给玛丽、约瑟夫和耶稣，即神圣的家族，圣家族大教堂。博科贝拉雇佣的第一位建筑师干了一年后就辞职了，于是他开始寻找新的人选。
Legend goes, Bokovea had a dream one night. The gingerhead blue eyedokobea saw the person from his dream in real life, drawing in the studio of another architect he knew. The man he had seen was Antony Galdie, and immediately Bokobea hired him to be the architect of his church. The greatest job in Spain at that time was given to this almost completely unknown 29-year-old who'd done very little work. The basic floor plan for La Segrada Familia had already been laid out by the former architect, and Gaudi would stick with it.
传说博科贝拉有一天晚上做了一个梦。这个红发蓝眼的博科贝拉在现实生活中认出了他梦中的人，那个人正在他认识的另一位建筑师的工作室里画画。他看到的那个人就是安东尼·高迪，博科贝拉立刻雇他担任自己教堂的建筑师。当时西班牙最伟大的工作交给了这位几乎完全默默无闻、年仅29岁且几乎没做什么作品的年轻人。圣家族大教堂的基本平面图已经由前一位建筑师规划好了，高迪将沿用它。
The church would be built in the Neogothic style, which is popular at the time in Europe. But Galadie also wanted the church to be something completely unique, inspired by nature and by God. What Galadie wanted was a building which would actually have the kind of harmonies of the celestial spheres, the idea of that everything has a harmony in nature.
这座教堂将以当时在欧洲流行的的新哥特式风格建造。但加拉迪也希望这座教堂完全独特，受到自然和上帝的启发。加拉迪想要的是一座真正拥有天球和谐感建筑，这种理念即万物在自然中皆有和谐。
And that if you got that right in your building, the building itself would spiritualize you. That said, Gaudi would never allow the building to outshine God's creations, so he set a limit on how tall the church would ever get. He felt that he didn't want to be tall than God's handiwork and God's handiwork, where of course the mountains mountains on either side. Lassegradah Familia would be one meter or about three feet, shorter than Mount Manjuic in Barcelona,
如果你在建筑中把这一点做对了，建筑本身就会使你精神升华。话虽如此，高迪绝不允许这座建筑盖过上帝的造物，因此他为教堂的高度设定了限制。他觉得自己不想比上帝的手工艺品更高，而上帝的手工艺品当然就是两边的山脉。圣家族大教堂将比巴塞罗那的蒙特惠奇山矮一米，大约三英尺，
just to keep it humble. In 1883, when Gaudi started work on Lassegradah Familia, his first matter of business was to finish the crypt, which had been started by the previous architect. The crypt is essentially a small church under the bigger church and a place where important people are buried. In fact, Joseph Bocabea was buried there when he died in 1892, nine years after he hired Gaudi.
只是为了保持谦逊。1883年，当高迪开始建造圣家族大教堂时，他要处理的第一件事就是完成由前一位建筑师开始建造的地下室。地下室本质上是宏大教堂下方的一座小教堂，也是埋葬重要人物的地方。事实上，1892年何塞·博卡贝拉去世时就被埋葬在那里，那是他雇佣高迪九年后。
The Cigrada Familia crypt was big enough to hold services in, and this kept everyone happy while Gaudi took his time designing the rest of the building. When Bokobea died, management of the construction passed through various hands, but for Galadhi, there was only one client that really mattered. God is the client and God is never in a hurry. After the Crypt was finished, Galadhi began to build the first big wall of the building, the Nativity facade. He would work on it for the rest of his life, but it was important to him that this facade
圣家族大教堂的地下室大到足以举行礼拜，这让所有人都很高兴，而高迪则花时间设计建筑的其余部分。博科贝拉死后，建设的管理权经由多方之手，但对加拉迪来说，真正重要的客户只有一个。上帝是客户，而上帝从不着急。地下室完工后，加拉迪开始建造这座建筑的第一面大墙——诞生立面。他将在余生中为之工作，但对他来说，这面立面必须
get done first, because... It would be the Bible written in stone, which people, if they couldn't even read or write, they could look at the building and be told about the values of the Catholic faith. Gaudi was a sculptor as much as an architect, and the wall would be full of stone sculptures depicting biblical scenes. The baptism of Christ, Christ in the workshop with his father, the flight to Egypt, with a life-sized donkey. The stone sculpture of a donkey in that scene was actually cast in plaster from a real
首先完成，因为……这将是用石头写成的圣经，人们即使不识字，也能看着这座建筑并了解天主教信仰的价值观。高迪既是一位雕塑家也是一位建筑师，这面墙将布满描绘圣经场景的石头雕塑。基督受洗、基督与父亲在作坊中、逃往埃及（带有真人大小的驴）。该场景中驴的石雕实际上是用一头真正的活驴通过石膏铸造的。
live donkey. It had to be a particular donkey. He wanted a donkey that looked as if it had been through the desert for 40 days. One of Gaudi's workers actually wandered the streets until he found the perfect starving donkey, which he exactly handed over to Gaudi. He took the donkey and he put the donkey up in a harness. He'd had it chloroformed. And then he cast the whole live donkey. He'd had it chloroformed, and then he cast the whole live donkey. Anthony Gaudi also tried making plaster molds from live human beings.
那必须是一头特定的驴。他想要一头看起来像是穿过了40天沙漠的驴。高迪的一名工人实际上在街上游荡，直到找到那头完美的快要饿死的驴，然后准确地交给了高迪。他带走了驴，并给驴套上了挽具。他给它用了氯仿。然后他把整头活驴给铸模了。他给它用了氯仿，然后他把整头活驴给铸模了。安东尼·高迪还尝试用活人制作石膏模具。
He actually tried to do with one of his workers, but he almost killed him and decided that maybe that wasn't the best way forward. This all took an incredibly long time, but eventually the wall started to tell a story in stone, and it featured hundreds of celestial and earthly creatures. Little snails crawling all over it and tortoises. The facade became crowded and cluttered and teeming with life. Kind of almost swampish, kind of quality of the stone oozing kind of organic shaping of the building. It was very unusual, very extraordinary.
他实际上对他的一个工人尝试过，但他差点把他弄死，并决定这可能不是最好的前进方式。这一切花费了极其长的时间，但最终这面墙开始用石头讲述一个故事，它以数百个天界和尘世生物为特色。小蜗牛在它上面到处爬，还有乌龟。立面变得拥挤杂乱，生机勃勃。石头有一种几乎像沼泽般的品质，渗出建筑有机形状的塑造。这是非常不同寻常的，非常非凡的。
Antony Gaudi was slowly building a Catholic church, but not everyone was convinced that Catholicism had anything of value to offer the average working citizen. Leftist saw the church as getting rich from the tithes of the poor. They saw them as being wealthy, as being parasitic, as living off them. Communism, socialism, and anarchism were taking hold in other parts of the world, and in Spain, these leftist parties thought they could offer the struggling worker a better life. Conflict between leftists and the state and leftists and the church were a constant. For the last decade of the 19th century, there's probably on average something like two bombs every week in the center of the city. Throughout the years, Gaudi worked
安东尼·高迪在慢慢建造一座天主教教堂，但并非所有人都确信天主教能为普通工人阶级提供任何有价值的东西。左翼分子认为这座教堂靠穷人的什一税发财。他们认为他们很富有，是寄生虫，靠他们生活。共产主义、社会主义和无政府主义正在世界其他地方生根发芽，在西班牙，这些左翼政党认为他们可以为苦难中的工人提供更好的生活。左翼与国家之间以及左翼与教堂之间的冲突不断。在19世纪的最后十年里，市中心平均大概每星期发生大约两起炸弹袭击。这些年来，高迪一直在
on other architecture projects in Barcelona. His work is peppered all over the city. In palaces, pavilions, and extravagant homes, his sinuous and skeletal architecture was unmistakable. Everyone in Barcelona knew his style. But La Segrada Familia is the project that consumed him. He realized, of course, that he could never finish it and would never see it finished in his lifetime. By 1926, 73-year-old Anthony Gaudi had never married
巴塞罗那开展其他建筑项目。他的作品点缀在整座城市里。在宫殿、凉亭和奢华的住宅中，他那蜿蜒且富有骨感的建筑风格是不可磨灭的。巴塞罗那的每个人都知道他的风格。但圣家族大教堂才是那个消耗了他心血的项目。当然，他意识到自己永远无法完成它，也永远无法在有生之年看到它完工。到1926年，73岁的安东尼·高迪从未结过婚，
and was living alone. He spent a lot of nights sleeping in his studio at Las Agrata Familia to obsess with his work to care about his appearance. He was looking a bit like a tramp, actually, because trousers were held up with safety pins and a bit of string. On June 7, 1926, Gaudi is leaving work, and as he crosses the railroad tracks... He forgets to look, and the tram runs him over. Anthony Gaudi was left nearly dead on the railroad tracks.
并且独自生活。他花了很多晚上睡在圣家族大教堂的工作室里，对工作过于痴迷以至于不关心自己的外表。他实际上看起来有点像个流浪汉，因为裤子是用安全别针和一根绳子撑起来的。1926年6月7日，高迪离开工作岗位，当他穿过铁轨时……他忘记看路，电车把他撞倒了。安东尼·高迪奄奄一息地倒在铁轨上。
When his body was found, he was taken to the hospital, Ray died three days later. Gaudi was buried in the crypt under La Segrada Familia. His last years had been consumed with building the church, but Barcelona had not forgotten Caldhi. The wrongs of people came out to mourn. It was guess that almost a quarter of the population of Catalonia turned up in procession, hundreds of thousands of people were there.
当他的遗体被发现时，他被送往医院，三天后雷去世了。高迪被安葬在圣家族大教堂下方的地下室里。他晚年的大部分时间都在建造这座教堂，但巴塞罗那并没有忘记加拉迪。成群结队的人们出来哀悼。据猜测，加泰罗尼亚近四分之一的人口参加了游行队伍，几十万人聚集在那里。
When Gaudi died, he left behind a largely unfinished church, which stood was a massive wall, the Nativity Fissade, one tower and the crypt. His colleagues and apprentices would have a lot to do to bring his full vision into being. But Gaudi had anticipated that other architects would finish his work, and he left behind detailed drawings and models outlining exactly how he wanted his magnum opus to be built. For ten years work on Las Gras a familiar continued very slowly.
高迪去世时，留下一座基本未完成的教堂，矗立着一面巨大的墙——诞生立面、一座塔楼和地下室。他的同事和学徒们需要做很多工作才能将他的完整构想变为现实。但高迪预料到其他建筑师会完成他的工作，并留下了详细的图纸和模型，确切勾勒出他希望如何建造他的传世之作。在随后的十年里，圣家族大教堂的建设工作进展得非常缓慢。
Much of Gaudi's former team stayed on, even though they could have gone and started their own projects. They were loyal. even though they could have gone and started their own projects. They were loyal. There was still work to be done. The drawings still existed. They continued working away. And then in 1936. The youth of Spain from the North, East, South and West,
高迪以前的大多数团队都留了下来，尽管他们本可以离开并开始他们自己的项目。他们很忠诚。尽管他们本可以离开并开始他们自己的项目。他们很忠诚。还有工作要做。图纸仍然存在。他们继续埋头工作。然后到了1936年。
go forth to spill the life's blood of their Bella Stanyard. The Spanish Civil War began. The decades old conflict between leftists and the state had finally come to a head. The Republicans who were in alliance of various leftist parties fought against the nationalists, which was an alliance of fascists and other conservatives led by General Francisco Franco. The nationalists also had the support of most of Spain's Catholic clergy. On the 18th of July, two days after the start of the Spanish Civil War, a group of young anarchists
西班牙北、东、南、西的青年，出征去洒下他们美丽的西班牙的热血。西班牙内战爆发了。几十年来左翼与国家之间的冲突终于达到了白热化。由各种左翼政党组成的联盟——共和国派，与由弗朗西斯科·佛朗哥将军领导的法西斯分子和其他保守派联盟——国民军进行了战斗。国民军也得到了西班牙大部分天主教神职人员的支持。7月18日，即西班牙内战爆发两天后，一群年轻的无政府主义者
break into the studios of Gaudi and smash everything with hammers. All the models, everything is smashed up into tiny little bits. When they're done smashing, they light the place of place. Everything burns, including the architectural drawings. Absolutely everything. And in fact, the following day, try to come back
闯入高迪的工作室，用锤子砸碎了一切。所有的模型，一切都被砸成细小的碎块。当他们砸完后，他们点燃了那个地方。一切都被烧毁了，包括建筑图纸。绝对的一切。事实上，第二天，他们试着回来
and bomb the initivity facade, which is the only work standing there of Gaudes, which miraculously they fail to do. Cophalysis was under attack during the war. And by the end of it, 40 churches in Barcelona had been destroyed, and 12 people associated with the Sagrada Familia Project, including some of its managing patrons and clergy, had been killed. The war ended in 1939, the leftist lost, the fascist won, and General Francisco Franco
并试图轰炸诞生立面，这是高迪唯一耸立在那里的作品，奇迹般地他们没有炸毁。战争期间，天主教受到攻击。到战争结束时，巴塞罗那有40座教堂被毁，与圣家族大教堂项目相关的12人（包括一些管理资助人和神职人员）被杀害。战争于1939年结束，左翼失败了，法西斯获胜了，弗朗西斯科·佛朗哥将军
took control of Spain. When it was all over, a few workers returned to Gaudi's studio to salvage what they could. They very carefully picked up in boxes, little sections and fragments of the models, and like archaeologists do today, they started piecing them together. For the next couple of decades, the remaining architects and other workers tried to figure out how to move forward on the construction without Gaudi's plans.
夺取了西班牙的控制权。这一切结束时，一些工人回到高迪的工作室，试图抢救他们所能抢救的东西。他们非常小心地把模型的小部分和碎片收集到箱子里，就像今天的考古学家所做的那样，他们开始将它们拼凑起来。在接下来的几十年里，剩下的建筑师和其他工人试图弄清楚如何在没有高迪图纸的情况下继续推进施工。
But outside the church, there was opposition to moving forward at all. In the 1960s, an impressive group of intellectuals and architects, including L'Augau Bucie and Alvar Alto, wrote an open letter opposing the continuation of Lossagrata Familia. Gaudi wasn't only an architect, they argued. He was an artist, and you shouldn't attempt to finish a work of art without the artist. They felt that this was a total waste of time. They should have left just the original Intivity facade,
但在教堂外面，有反对继续建造的声音。在20世纪60年代，一群令人印象深刻的知识分子和建筑师，包括勒·柯布西耶和阿尔瓦·阿尔托，写了一封公开信，反对继续建造圣家族大教堂。他们认为，高迪不仅是一位建筑师。他是一位艺术家，你不应该在没有艺术家的参与下去完成一件艺术品。他们觉得这完全是在浪费时间。他们本该只留下最初的诞生立面，
almost like a Gothic ruin, there as a homage to Gaudi, and that Gaudi wasn't being well served. But the patrons of the project would have none of it. The building was never supposed to be an homage to Gaudi, they argued. It was always about something bigger. That said, they would try to honor Gaudi's original vision as faithfully as possible, but
几乎就像一个哥特式废墟，作为对高迪的致敬，这样做才是没有亏待高迪。但该项目的赞助商坚决不听这些。他们认为，这座建筑从来都不是为了向高迪致敬。它一直关乎更宏大的事物。话虽如此，他们会尽可能忠实地向高迪最初的愿景致敬，但
it wouldn't be easy. The models and drawings had been the roadmap for how to move forward on the construction, and they were burned and smashed to pieces. And this wasn't just any cathedral. All these years, Gaudi had been designing something so unique, so complex and so completely new, that it would take his successor years to fully get a handle on it. By the 1970s, another huge façade was going up, but the church still had no interior and no roof.
这并不容易。模型和图纸曾是推进施工的路线图，但它们被烧毁并砸成了碎片。而且这不仅仅是任何一座教堂。这么多年来，高迪设计的东西是如此独特、如此复杂、如此完全崭新，以至于他的继任者需要花上几年时间才能完全掌握它。到20世纪70年代，另一个巨大的立面正在拔地而起，但教堂仍然没有内部也没有屋顶。
It was just walls and towers, a construction site, open to the rain. I first went to Barcelona in 1977 when I was 20. That's architect Mark Burry. Mark had actually been told in architecture school that Gaudi was not worth studying because his approach was too esoteric. He was too extraordinary and there was no school, meaning that there was nothing to see move along. This just got very more curious, so he went to have a look at the Sograta familiar himself. And my complete accident, I ended up meeting the two 90-year-old architects who were directing the project and they had been young architects listening to
它只有墙壁和塔楼，是一个暴露在雨中的建筑工地。我第一次去巴塞罗那是在1977年，当时我20岁。那是建筑师马克·伯里。马克在建筑学校时实际上被告知，高迪不值得研究，因为他的方法太深奥了。他太不寻常了，而且没有学派，这意味着没有什么可看的，走开吧。这反而让人更好奇了，于是他亲自去看看圣家族大教堂。阴差阳错地，我遇到了两位90岁的建筑师，他们正在指导这个项目，他们曾经是年轻的建筑师，
Galdi, explaining his latest discoveries when they were students. The old architects were ready to move on to the interior of the building, but they didn't exactly know how to do it. They knew that he had a system based on geometry and they knew this system worked translating to a kind of building methodology. In other words, the architects knew it was theoretically possible to figure out how to create the rest of the church, but it was a monumental task. They pointed Burry to a couple of boxes. Boxes full of broken models, plans to pair us models, with the invitation to come and join the team
在他们还是学生的时候听加拉迪解释他的最新发现。年长的建筑师们准备转向建筑内部的建造，但他们并不确切知道该怎么做。他们知道他有一个基于几何学的系统，并且他们知道这个系统可以通过转化为一种建筑方法论来发挥作用。换句话说，建筑师们知道在理论上弄清楚如何创造教堂的其余部分是可能的，但这是一项巨大的任务。他们把伯里带到几个箱子前。装满破碎模型的箱子，配对模型的计划，并邀请他加入团队，
and have a go and untank the mysteries of the models. For a year, Burry worked with the models, trying to extrapolate the geometry of the rest of the church based on the pieces he had. After a year, he'd managed to draw out architectural blueprints for one window. It was a start. Mark Burry didn't stay long at the Sagrada Familia.
去尝试解开这些模型的奥秘。在长达一年的时间里，伯里一直在研究这些模型，试图根据他手头的碎片推断出教堂其余部分的几何形状。一年后，他设法画出了一扇窗户的建筑蓝图。这是一个开始。马克·伯里在圣家族大教堂待的时间不长。
He was only 20 and he had to go back to New Zealand to finish school. He returned to work on the church 10 years later and found that when he was gone, a new thing in my bob had been moved into the office, a computer. So I thought these computers must have something to offer because I'd never actually personally touched one. When Burry finally touched the computer, he figured
他当时只有20岁，必须回新西兰完成学业。10年后他回到教堂工作，发现他离开期间，办公室里搬进了一样新东西——一台电脑。所以我想这些电脑一定有可取之处，因为我其实从来没亲自摸过一台。当伯里终于摸到电脑时，他发现
out that it had architectural software on it. But the software wasn't capable of dealing with Gaudi. Couldn't even go anywhere near what Gaudi was trying to do. The complexity of Gaudi's designs was too much for architectural software of the early 90s. Burry wondered if there was anyone else who designed with similar geometric complexity, and finally he landed on it. People who design airplanes. He started using aeronautical software to figure out an architectural strategy for the interior of the church.
上面有建筑软件。但该软件无法处理高迪的设计。甚至无法接近高迪试图做的事情。高迪设计的复杂性对于90年代初的建筑软件来说太难了。伯里想知道是否还有其他人以类似几何复杂性进行设计，最终他想到了。设计飞机的人。他开始使用航空软件来找出教堂内部的建筑策略。
And because I had this very sophisticated software by accident, I discovered parametric design. So we were working parametrically from 1991. Parametric design uses computer algorithms to allow you to plug in different variables and see what the end result is each time you change something. Mark Burry was one of the first architects to use computers to design this way. Though we eventually figured out that Frank Geary's team had also started using aeronautical software to bring Geary's strangely shaped, curvaceous buildings into being. Every year I would go through LA and visit Frank's office and talk to the technical team and compare notes.
由于我偶然拥有了这款非常复杂的软件，我发现了参数化设计。所以我们从1991年开始进行参数化工作。参数化设计使用计算机算法，允许你输入不同的变量，并在每次更改某些东西时查看最终结果。马克·伯里是最早使用计算机以这种方式进行设计的建筑师之一。虽然我们最终发现弗兰克·盖里的团队也开始使用航空软件来将盖里那些奇特形状、曲线优美的建筑变为现实。每年我都会去洛杉矶拜访弗兰克的办公室，与技术团队交谈并交换意见。
Eventually Geary technologies with help from Mark Burry went on to create their own parametric design software, specifically for architects. And by the early 2000s, many of the most exciting new projects in architecture were being done this way. At the forefront of this was a church designed over a century ago by Anthony Galdi, Las Agrada Familia. So from being the sort of anachronism and interesting, but irrelevant, it became actually the lead project in the whole of the digital revolution of architecture. Paramedic design allowed Mark Murray and the other architects to move a lot faster on the interior of the church. Without this technology, it's possible there would still be no inside the sea.
最终，盖里的技术在马克·伯里的帮助下，继续创建了他们自己的参数化设计软件，专门为建筑师服务。到2000年代初，建筑领域许多最令人兴奋的新项目都是通过这种方式完成的。这其中最前沿的是一个由安东尼·加拉迪一个多世纪前设计的教堂——圣家族大教堂。因此，它从某种过时且有趣但无关紧要的东西，实际上变成了整个建筑数字革命的领先项目。参数化设计让马克·伯里和其他建筑师在教堂内部的建设上进展快得多。如果没有这项技术，里面可能至今仍是一片空白。
It was only a few years ago, in 2010, that the architects were able to put the finishing touches on the interior. Now people line up around the block to get a glimpse inside. And it really is breathtaking, partly because of these incredibly tall columns that Gaudi designed, that branch out like trees at the top and are capable of carrying a tremendous amount of weight. When people go into that building, I'm not suggesting that it's necessarily always a religious experience, but the shock and surprise of walking in through those doors into this explosion of light. The light pours in through giant stained glass windows.
就在几年前，即2010年，建筑师们才得以对内部进行最后精雕细琢的修饰。现在，人们排着长队绕过街区去窥探内部。它确实令人叹为观止，部分原因在于高迪设计的这些极其高大的柱子，它们在顶部像树木一样展开，能够承受巨大的重量。当人们走进那座建筑时，我并不是说这必然总是一种宗教体验，但通过那些大门走进这片光芒爆炸的震撼和惊讶。光线透过巨大的彩色玻璃窗倾泻而下。
In the afternoon, it's a red orange light and in the morning it's a blueish green light and it filters through the huge tree-like columns. You feel like you're in a forest. And you feel very tiny. You feel very small. You feel as if there's a whole kind of universe above you. But the building is still not finished. but the building is still not finished. I'm in an extremely loud metal cage elevator that runs on the outside of the church with Hironimo Bouchario,
下午是红橙色的光，早晨是蓝绿色的光，它们透过巨大的树状柱子过滤进来。你感觉自己置身于森林中。你觉得自己非常微小。你觉得自己非常渺小。你觉得自己仿佛头顶上有一整片宇宙。但这座建筑仍然没有完工。但这座建筑仍然没有完工。我坐着一个噪音极大的金属笼式电梯，它在教堂外部运行，同行的有希罗尼莫·布查里奥，
the architect who you met at the very beginning of the story and Anna Beorby, who handles press for La Sacrata Familia. Everything is very safe here, eh? Yes. It's very safe, Ana says, but it doesn't feel that safe. The elevator is shaking and we can see Barcelona getting smaller below us as we rattle up alongside the towers of the church. The elevator door opens to a spectacular view.
就是你在故事最开始遇到的那位建筑师，以及安娜·贝比，她负责圣家族大教堂的新闻事务。这里一切都很安全，对吧？是的。安娜说这非常安全，但感觉没那么安全。电梯在晃动，当我们沿着教堂的塔楼喀哒喀哒地往上升时，我们可以看到巴塞罗那在我们脚下变得越来越小。电梯门打开，展现出壮丽的景色。
Oh, wow, wow, wow, wow. I'm breathed. They come on all. It's the eye. I'm breathed. We are standing on the top of the Sagrada Familia. We have the part of the there. Barcelona's city blocks stretch out all around us.
哦，哇，哇，哇，哇。我屏住了呼吸。他们都来了。那是眼睛。我屏住了呼吸。我们正站在圣家族大教堂的顶部。我们有那里的部分。巴塞罗那的城市街区在我们周围延伸开来。
To the east, we can see the Mediterranean Sea and to the south, the mountain that Gaudi promised not to surpass. When the building is finished there will be 18 towers including a new one right where I'm standing. This one will be the tallest of all reaching to 560 feet or 170 meters. reaching to 560 feet or 170 meters. Hironimo is working on designing it right now, and he's using the fragments of Gaudi's plaster models to figure out how to do it. These will be Jesus Christ's Tower in the middle,
向东，我们可以看到地中海，向南，可以看到高迪承诺不超过高度的山。当建筑完工时，将有18座塔楼，包括就在我站立的这里的全新一座。这将是所有塔楼中最高的一座，达到560英尺或170米。达到560英尺或170米。希罗尼莫现在正致力于设计它，他正利用高迪石膏模型的碎片来弄清楚该怎么做。中间的这座将是耶稣基督之塔，
one of Angeles and the other four. The architects hope the building will be finished in 2026 on the 100th anniversary of Gaudi's death, but there is still a lot to be done. Meanwhile, some of the neighbors seem fed up with Las Agrata Familia and all of the congestion in tourists it brings to the neighborhood. Sometimes there are little protests against the place, like this one in 2011, where locals chanted, the more tourists
一座是天使之塔，另外四座是……建筑师们希望这座建筑能在2026年高迪逝世100周年之际完工，但仍有很多工作要做。与此同时，一些邻居似乎对圣家族大教堂以及它给社区带来的拥堵和游客感到厌烦。有时会有针对这个地方的小型抗议活动，比如2011年的这一次，当地人高呼，越多的游客
come. Over 130 years ago, Joseph Bocabae decided to build flasagradda familia to cleanse the people of Barcelona of their sins and inspire the common folk to live a religious life. He picked a piece of land on the outskirts of the city where cows and goats would sometimes wander. And he probably never imagined that it would become the tourist attraction it is today. Architect Hironimo Bouchario says one of the perks of working at La Sagrada Familia is getting to be inside the church when no one else is there.
来。130多年前，何塞·博卡贝拉决定建造圣家族大教堂，以洗刷巴塞罗那人民的罪孽，并激励普通民众过上宗教生活。他在城市边缘的一块土地上挑了一个地方，那里的奶牛和山羊有时会游荡到这里。他大概从未想象过它会成为如今这样的旅游胜地。建筑师希罗尼莫·布查里奥说，在圣家族大教堂工作的好处之一，就是能在没有其他人的时候进入教堂内部。
For me, it's really special to be alone or to be with not too many people. The church only holds one mass a month right now, and it can be hard as throngs of tourists bump into you with their selfie sticks to feel connected to the building as a place of worship. Hironimo let me come into the church with him in the early morning before it was connected to the building as a place of worship. Hironimo let me come into the church with him in the early morning before it was open to the public so that I could try to get his sense of it. You can feel that it's spiritual and that there is somebody or something more. God is in stands here.
对我来说，独自一人或与少数人在一起真的很特别。这座教堂现在一个月只举行一次弥萨，当成群结队的游客拿着自拍杆撞到你时，要想感受到与作为礼拜场所的建筑的联系可能会很困难。希罗尼莫让我在清晨向公众开放之前和他一起进入教堂，这样我就可以试着去感受他的那种感觉。你能感觉到它是灵性的，并且有某个人或某种更伟大的存在。上帝就站在这里。
To me, and I'm not a religious person, Lassagrada Familia is not so much a testament to God as it is to humans and what they can create. But Gaudi would dispute that assessment. He once said, the creation continues incessantly through the media of man. But man does not create. He discovers. Coming up, we discuss Gaudi's revolutionary models for the last sprout of familiar in a segment that was just too nerdy and dense for the beast itself, but it's, you know, just too cool not to mention it at all. That's right after this. One of the things we mentioned in the piece are these models that were destroyed and how
对我而言——而且我不是一个有宗教信仰的人——圣家族大教堂与其说是对上帝的证明，不如说是对人类及其所能创造的事物的证明。但高迪会反驳这种评估。他曾说过，创造通过人的媒介无休止地继续着。但人并不创造。他发现。接下来，我们将讨论高迪为圣家族大教堂设计的革命性模型，这个片段对节目本身来说实在太极客、太密集了，但你知道，它实在太酷了，不能不提。广告之后马上回来。我们在节目中提到的一件事就是那些被毁坏的模型，以及它们在实现
important they were in realizing Gaudi's vision for La Segrada Familia. And it was just a little too technical to get into in the piece, but Kurt Colstad knows this stuff. And I asked him to come into the studio and explain Gaudi's modeling technique and why it is so important to the creation of Las Grata Familia. Like a lot of architects, especially ones who'd like to use curves, Gaudi actually preferred to work in models rather than drawings. Models helped him experiment with really complex three dimensional structures. And often he would sort of model out structural arrangements, test things out, and then photograph
高迪对圣家族大教堂的构想方面有多么重要。这稍微有点太技术性了，无法在节目中深入探讨，但柯特·科尔斯塔德懂这些。我请他来到工作室，解释高迪的模型制作技术，以及为什么它对圣家族大教堂的建造如此重要。像许多建筑师一样，特别是那些喜欢使用曲线的建筑师，高迪实际上更喜欢用模型而不是图纸来工作。模型帮助他尝试真正复杂的三维结构。通常他会建立结构安排模型，测试各种东西，然后拍摄
those models and draw over the photographs. But the models were behind all of this. They were driving the design. And one of the things that he toyed with a lot in models were variations on what's called a catenary arch. Okay, so what is a catenary arch? So a catenary is the curved shape that a hanging chain assumes under its own weight. Basically picture electric line suspended between utility poles. Okay, so you're driving along the highway. You see two utility poles, electric line goes across them and there's that natural bowing of the electrical wire. And that is a catenary arch. Exactly. And that term is actually
这些模型并在照片上画画。但模型是所有这一切背后的支撑。它们推动着设计。他在模型中反复琢磨的一件事是对所谓的“悬链线拱”的各种变体。好的，那么什么是悬链线拱？悬链线是指悬挂的链条在自身重量下呈现的弯曲形状。基本上想象一下电线杆之间悬挂的电线。好的，所以你正沿着高速公路开车。你看到两根电线杆，电线横跨它们之间，电线会产生自然的下垂。这就是悬链线拱。完全正确。这个词实际上
derived from the Latin word for chain. And it was already well known by Gaudi's time that an optimal arch shape could be made by mirroring a catenary curve vertically. Basically, you take that hanging curve and you just flip it up and that becomes the model of your arch. And that arch distributes building loads efficiently and a lot of Gothic churches have them. Okay, so that makes sense. You take this bowed chain, it creates the optimal arch when you flip it over and when you're creating churches in the Gothic style, this is a good way to create a good model. But Gaudi took the idea further. He hung strings from other strings, from other strings, and then he added bird shot to wait them down
源自拉丁语中的“链条”。在高迪的时代，人们就已经众所周知，通过垂直翻转悬链线曲线可以做出最佳的拱形形状。基本上，你把那条下垂的曲线直接翻转过来，那就成了你拱门模型。这种拱门可以有效地分配建筑荷载，许多哥特式教堂都有它们。好的，这说得通。你拿着这根下垂的链条，把它翻转过来就创造出了最佳的拱门，当你在建造哥特式风格的教堂时，这是制作好模型的好方法。但高迪将这个想法推得更远。他将细绳从其他细绳上垂挂下来，再从那些细绳上垂挂下来，然后在
at structural intersections. And he'd created these huge and intricate wireframe models that ended up looking a bit like chandeliers. And then Gaudi would use mirrors to flip these vertically and study the shapes they created in order to shape his own elaborate building skeletons. And this sounds a lot like what later architects used software for when they did 3D modeling.
结构交汇处添加鸟弹（铅弹）来增加它们的重量。他创造了这些巨大而复杂的线框模型，最后看起来有点像枝形吊灯。然后高迪会使用镜子把这些模型垂直翻转，研究它们创造的形状，以便塑造他自己精致的建筑骨架。这听起来很像后来的建筑师在进行3D建模时使用的软件。
Yeah, there are a lot of parallels. In essence, long before parametric design was a computer software problem, Gaudi changed parameters in his models by moving strings and weights around to see how those individual modifications could reshape an entire structure. And then a century later, people came along and finally made these digital programs that could mimic what these handmade models had been doing, allowing architects to see how small changes would ripple out through their entire designs. So, you know, you can imagine they would take like a column and just move it around a little bit, and that deforms like all the other shapes of the structure around it.
是的，有很多相似之处。本质上，早在参数化设计成为计算机软件问题之前，高迪就通过移动细绳和重量来改变他模型中的参数，以观察这些单独的修改如何重塑整个结构。然后一个世纪后，人们出现了，最终制作出了能够模仿这些手工模型所做事情的数字程序，让建筑师能够看到微小的变化如何在他们的整个设计中产生涟漪效应。所以，你知道，你可以想象他们会拿一根柱子稍微移动一下，这就会使周围所有其他结构的形状发生变形。
Right. And then software you do this and you know, the software cranks along and does its thing. But in Gaudi's time, you would move a weight around and you'd see how the connected set of chains would all kind of deform by adding a little bit of bird shot to one little section. Exactly. And that's amazing. And it looks stunning. Yeah, the results are amazing.
没错。然后你在软件里这样做（你知道，软件会运转并做它该做的事）。但在高迪的时代，你会移动一个重量，然后通过在某一个小部分增加一点鸟弹，看看相连的一组链条将如何全部变形。完全正确。这太神奇了。而且看起来惊艳。是的，结果令人惊叹。
And so, and a lot of people, you know, they think Gaudi and they think of these beautiful sculptural scenes and these details he created. But underneath all of that is this really lovely structural logic. And in Cigarette Familia, those details are beautiful, but so is this internal framework of columns and arches and vaults that branches up and out and creates a kind of fractal forest inside. But because Gaudi didn't spend a lot of time teaching or explaining his methods or really writing about
因此，很多人（你知道）一想到高迪，就会想到这些美丽的雕塑场景和这些他创造的细节。但在所有这一切之下，是这种真正可爱的结构逻辑。在圣家族大教堂里，那些细节很美，但这种由向上和向外延伸并形成内部某种分形森林的柱子、拱门和穹顶组成的内部框架同样美丽。但由于高迪没有花很多时间教学或解释他的方法，也没有真正写下关于
his designs. And because his work was so out of sync with like what modernists were trying to do at the time, he didn't always get a lot of recognition from the architectural establishment. So he was like a stark attack but in hiding? Yeah, pretty much. Yeah, he's that rare stark attack who doesn't spend all of his time bragging about what he does. That's so cool. These models are really stunning. They're amazing to look at. And we have some pictures on our website, correct? Yes, we have a ton of pictures of these models that he made as well as these, you know, the really beautiful church that they helped create. Very cool. Thank you so much. 99% of visible was produced this week by Katie Mingle, Mix Intek production by Sharif
他的设计的文章。而且因为他的作品与当时现代主义者试图做的事情非常脱节，他并不总是得到建筑界的大量认可。所以他就像是一个隐秘的明星建筑师？是的，差不多。是的，他就是那种不把时间花在吹嘘自己所作所为上的罕见明星建筑师。太酷了。这些模型真的很惊艳。看起来太棒了。我们的网站上有一些照片，对吧？是的，我们有大量他制作的这些模型以及（你知道）它们帮助创造的非常美丽的教堂的照片。非常酷。非常感谢。本周的 99% 隐形由凯蒂·明格尔制作，音频混音由谢里夫
Yousif, Music by Sean Riel. Kurt Colstead is the digital director and the one among us who actually went to architecture school. The rest of the staff includes Avery Trollfum and Emmett Fitzgerald, Delaney Hall, Terran Maza, and me, Roman Mars. Special thanks to the folks at Las Agrada Familia for spending so much time showing us around. It was a true privilege. For more detail on everything you heard today, check out Guy's Van Hensbergen's new book,
优素福完成，音乐由肖恩·里尔创作。柯特·科尔斯塔德是数字总监，也是我们当中真正去读过建筑学校的人。其他工作人员包括艾弗里·特罗尔弗姆、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、德兰尼·霍尔、特兰·马扎以及我，罗曼·马尔斯。特别感谢圣家族大教堂的工作人员花那么多时间带我们参观。这真是莫大的荣幸。想了解今天听到的所有内容的更多详情，请查看盖斯·范·亨斯贝尔根的新书，
The Sacred Familia, Gaudese Heaven on Earth. We are a project of 91.7KLW in San Francisco, and produced on Radio Row, in beautiful, downtown, Oakland, California. 99% of visible as part of Radio Topiaia from PRX, a collective of the best most innovative shows in all of podcasting. We are supported by the Night Foundation and our listeners, just like you. You can find 99% of visible and joint discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet me at Roman Mars in the show at 99PI Orc, or on Instagram, Tumblr, and
圣家堂，高迪的人间天堂。我们是旧金山 91.7 KLW 的一个项目，制作于美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心电台街。99% Invisible 是 PRX 旗下 Radiotopia 的一部分，这是一个汇聚了播客界最优秀、最具创新性节目的联盟。我们得到了奈特基金会和像您一样的听众的支持。您可以在 Facebook 上找到 99% Invisible 并参与节目的讨论。您可以在 Twitter 上 @Roman Mars，或关注节目的账号 @99PI.org，也可以在 Instagram、Tumblr 和
Reddit too. If you want to read an article about the oldest national monuments in the US or any of the other design stories that we release every single week, you have to go to our website. It's 99pi.org. PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
Reddit 上找到我们。如果您想阅读有关美国最古老的国家纪念碑的文章，或是我们每周发布其他任何设计故事，请访问我们的网站 99pi.org。PRX。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。